the neolithic wonder in southern england
known as stonehenge has puzzled
historians archaeologists and curious
tourists for centuries
answers to basis questions surrounding
the iconic monument have been elusive
including
how it was built and why and where did
the towering sandstone boulders come
from
now on that last question the origin of
the stones may
finally have been solved ian lee shows
us the breakthrough with an american
connection
[Applause]
a layer of mystery is peeled back at
stonehenge
exposing the unknown to the light
a year ago a seemingly unremarkable
rod of rock returned to the historical
site
back then susan greeney saw something
different
so for geologists this is the holy grail
really for stonehenge
did it turn out to be the holy grail
well in some ways yes
it's enabled uh some analysis that
wouldn't have otherwise been able to
take place
and finally pinpoint exactly where the
stars and stones came from
but that chunk of rock initially
disappeared in 1958 the british
government commissioned a major
restoration project
to make stonehenge safer and to help
historians better understand the
monument
workers drilled through the largest of
the sarson rocks removing
three stone cores robert phillips took
one home
the rest were discarded so if so much
could be determined from a small sample
you'd be forgiven for asking why another
wasn't taken
well stonehenge is completely unique
it's the only lintelled stone circle in
the world
and it's four and a half thousand years
old we don't really want to be taking
bits of it away you can see quite
clearly the
it was a bit of a homecoming when
phillips's sons returned the family
heirloom from the united states
where they did the drilling also really
exciting but it was a good luck really
you know the call being returned to us
from america just happened to coincide
with some geological work that was
already taking place
geologists trace the 20-ton giants to
westwoods
an area 15 miles north of stonehenge
they're pretty much some of the largest
stars and stones in the whole of
southern britain
so it seems that the people who were
building stonehenge were selecting
deliberately large stones
why not build stonehenge where they
quarried the stones why move them so far
that's a really good question and not
one that we can really answer at the
moment
other than to say that really stonehenge
and the whole landscape around it which
is chock full of lots of other
prehistoric monuments must have been
significant what possibly could be
significant
about this corner of britain i think
he's always going to be slightly out of
our grass
we're taking tiny steps towards that all
the time but i think there'll always be
something of a mystery about exactly why
an ancient mystery that keeps the magic
of stonehenge
alive for cbs this morning
ian lee in london a little bit of that
mystery solved now after 4 500 years
thank you ian